ADAM CARPENTER: Hi, everybody.
Welcome back from break.
My name is Adam Carpenter, and
I lead Google Play's Developer
Business Growth Initiative.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
And I'm Moonlit.
I'm a Business Development
Manager at Google Play Games.
ADAM CARPENTER:
Over the next hour,
you're going to hear
a number of talks
about how to optimize your
game's post-launch performance.
In this session,
we're going to talk
about identifying opportunities
in your game's data.
First, we're going
to show you how
to structure a nimble
product team that's empowered
to make data-driven decisions.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: Second,
from our experiences
of working with, and
for each of us, part
of Google top game
developers, what
are the top five analytics
questions to gauge your game's
performance.
ADAM CARPENTER: And last,
why a culture of transparency
will be critical to your
game's success and growth.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: Let's dive in.
In my years working
the gaming industry,
it's clear that to improve
a game's performance,
we must first understand your
players' behavior through data.
But the question is, what's
the right data to track?
Adam, in your experience,
what's that one piece of advice
you give to a new developer?
ADAM CARPENTER:
Record everything.
And I know this gets said a
lot, but it's very, very true.
Your players' kind of
engagement, participation data,
it's absolutely priceless, and
it's impossible to recreate.
If you're not recording it
when the actions are happening,
there's no way to get it back.
So even if you're
a tiny developer,
and you're unable to leverage
many of the third party
analytics solutions
that are out there,
at least try to record your
data into a flat file format.
If you have it
saved off somewhere,
you can always eventually suck
it up into a data warehouse,
begin to slice and
dice it, and understand
where your players find
value, and what opportunities
exist to grow your business.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: Assuming
you are recording everything
and making it accessible,
but the data cannot interpret
itself.
To draw the right insights
and create right action plans
based on these
insights, you need
to have the right people
in the right structure.
So the next step is to
build the right team.
In my experience,
many developers
set up their product
management and analysts teams
in what I call a classic model.
In this team structure, you
have the PMs sit in one group,
and analysts sit in a
completely separate group.
ADAM CARPENTER:
Maybe it's a case
of the analysts being
part of a central services
team, while the PMs,
they're embedded
within the game team itself.
In some other scenarios, both
the analysts and the PMs,
they're integrated
within to the game team.
But unfortunately,
they might have
different leaders who have
completely different agendas.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: Does this
sound familiar to anyone?
ADAM CARPENTER:
In this setup, it
might feel like there's
this huge, monolithic wall
in between the two groups.
PMs, they're not able or
willing to play with the data,
and the analysts, while
they have access to data,
they're not empowered
to drive any change.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: In
this team structure,
it often feels like PMs will
throw a question over the wall,
letting analysts work
on it for some time,
and just wait for
the final answer.
Then, depending on how
well-formed the question is,
or what the request is,
the analysts' answer
can vary a lot.
ADAM CARPENTER: Sometimes
it's meaningful,
other times it's
just a data dump.
And then in some cases, it
takes so long for the analysts
to generate an answer, that
the PMs have completely
moved on by the time
they get their response.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
Setup like this
can create a whole
lot of problems
that are counterproductive
to having
an agile, collaborative,
and responsive team.
Too often than we'd
like, both parties
might think that thinking the
worst about their counterparts.
ADAM CARPENTER: Mm-hmm.
PMs will often wonder
why it takes so long,
and when they do get an
answer, it isn't really
what they're looking for.
And then analysts,
on the other hand,
they're often really frustrated
by the poorly-formed questions
they get from PMs,
and they're often
left wondering if the PMs
are just asking questions
to waste their time.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
On both sides, you
have people thinking those
on the other side of the wall
just don't get the business.
Adam, do you have
any suggestions?
ADAM CARPENTER: So if you want
a small and nimble team, one
that's really empowered to
drive meaningful change--
business performance --break
away from the standard model.
Get rid of that wall between
your PMs and your analysts.
And in fact, I'll
go one step further.
Get rid of the concept
that PMs and analysts
need to be separate people.
For most of us game
devs, we're not
trying to make tiny
poor performance
improvements to our titles--
changes which require
a tease test just
to know if the results
are significant.
To use a baseball
analogy, we're at bat,
and we're swinging
for singles, doubles,
and the occasional home run.
Results, which when viewed in
the context of an A/B test,
are immediate and obvious.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: What
we're referring to here
is a hybrid model where
your PM and analyst
the very same person.
This role structure can
unleash their potential
by giving them autonomy,
domain expertise, and purpose.
ADAM CARPENTER: Set your
PM/analyst hybrids up
so they own a critical
vertical in the game,
and then empower them.
Look to your PMs
to write queries,
retrieve the data,
slice and dice
it to form a complete and full
understanding of the problem,
as well as a hypothesis
about what the solution is.
Then have them partner
with your engineers,
your creative
designers, your artists
to come up with a solution.
And once the solution
has been implemented--
the new feature --own it.
Monitor the results post-launch.
Make sure you're
iterating, and optimizing,
and constantly trying
to improve and identify
vectors for change.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: In summary,
to empower your team members,
give them real ownership
over the product roadmap,
and the ability to conduct
hypothesis-driven testing.
Give them the freedom to
choose the resources to let
them work on improving
your game's performance.
Now suppose you have
the right team in place.
To unleash their
potential, leverage
the power of innate curiosity.
ADAM CARPENTER:
Empower your team,
and encourage them to ask
critical questions about what's
actually happening in your game.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: One of
the most frequently asked
questions I get
from my developers
is that we track and
see a lot of data.
But what questions do we ask
to understand if our game is
actually performing well?
Here's some to get you started.
But most importantly, take
these as the inspiration
for the type of data
you ask your team,
and for your team
to ask themselves.
ADAM CARPENTER: Consider
how your new installs
are performing.
Are they returning the day
after their first session?
And if they are, how much time
are they actually spending
playing the game?
Likewise, think about how we can
better quantify and understand
what brings players back to
the game each and every day,
and when they do return, where
are they perceiving value?
Additionally, think about
drilling deeper and deeper
into the metrics, and moving
away from lagging indicators
like revenue and DAU.
Instead try to focus on finding
meaningful participation
metrics which can serve
as leading indicators.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: Let's take a
look at our top five in detail.
For those of you who
attended our Playtime event
or read our Medium
article, you may
be familiar with the concept
that your players' first 10
minutes in your game
is an early indicator
of the next-day retention.
We recommend that you
plot the following graph.
On the x-axis, you
have the average number
of minutes your players
spend in your game
on their very
first day, against,
on the y-axis, the
percentage of players
who come back on day two.
ADAM CARPENTER: Usually
what we would expect to see
is that with each
successive minute played,
a greater percentage of
users are likely to return.
However using
Google Play's data,
we've been able to identify two
negative patterns in the game,
that when you look at
your own game data,
you can identify opportunities
for growing and improving
your retention.
The first pattern,
which we call the flats,
retention is largely flat for
the first 5 to 10 minutes.
And the second
pattern, which we've
dubbed the gorge,
which you can actually
see your retention dropping over
the first three to five minutes
before it begins to rise.
If you see either of these
two patterns in your own data,
it suggests that there are
significant opportunities
to improve your early retention.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
To all the PMs,
analysts, and business owners in
the audience, plot this graph.
And if your see either of
these improvement signals,
be very curious what's
actually causing it.
Is it a very large
secondary download?
Is it your tutorial?
Is it the very confusing lobby?
Or maybe you are overly
aggressive in terms
monetization in the first
five minutes of game play.
All of these can heavily
impact your first-time user
experience, and thus
lower your retention.
ADAM CARPENTER: After
you've gotten your new users
to come back over
the first few days,
think about what's keeping
them there in the long term,
and whether they're spending
more or less time in your game.
To see that, you can
take a look at the graph
on the right-hand side.
What it shows is
the average amount
of time per user in
the install cohort
who returned on a given day.
The x-axis is the number of days
since the user's first session,
and the y-axis is, again,
that average amount
of time per active user.
It's an important
to view, as it's
going to help you understand
the extent to which
your new installs are spending
greater or lesser amounts
of time in your game.
In almost all the games that
we've looked at, what you see
is this very sharp rise from
the day one minute to the day
two minutes.
This is driven largely by
the low-quality installs
that you get in that
first day churning out,
and the users who come
back on the next day
being exceptionally engaged.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
Past day 10, you
may see one of the
following three patterns:
growing, stable, or declining.
There's no one right
answer to this.
Most importantly, take
this as a starting point
to investigate what's
driving user behavior.
Think about what the
in-game experience
is like from their perspective.
For example, if the
minutes per active install
grows significantly
over time, is it
because of overall
low retention,
where only your most loyal
players remain, or is it
because players think they
have to spend a lot of time
in your game in
order to succeed?
On the other hand, you might
have a very amazing feature
that's only available
after level 20, 30, or 40.
ADAM CARPENTER: If average
play time is shrinking,
think about what
might be causing that.
Is it as case of content?
Your game just
doesn't have enough,
and despite the fact
that players really
want to engage in play, there
isn't enough for them to do.
Also, think about how your
game economy is structured.
Is it too tight?
Are you squeezing your players?
And are you forcing them
to pay too early such
that they can't spend
enough time in the game,
and they're more
likely to churn out.
We'd strongly encourage you
to go back to your development
teams, generate plots
like this, and then be
curious about what's actually
happening in your game, what
patterns you're seeing.
Because being curious about how
your new players are engaging
in the game will set you up
for success by helping you
understand what gameplay aspects
might be helping or hindering
your game's performance.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: For your
broad DAU base, have you
thought about what brings
them back each and every day?
A view we particularly
like, segment your DAU
based on when your players
were last active in your game.
For example, take all of
today's DAU, and group them
based on what percentage
is from new installs.
What percentage was
active yesterday,
what percentage was active
two to four days ago,
so on and so forth.
ADAM CARPENTER: When
viewing a graph like this,
what you're trying to do is
maximize the percent of DAU
who was last active yesterday,
because this would mean
that a majority of your
users are coming back
to the game each and every day.
Now it's unlikely you
will ever get to 100%
last active yesterday,
but that should
be all of our stretch goals.
And for each segment
besides those who are active
the day before, think
about what their needs are,
where their interests lie.
Think about how you can provide
better experiences, better
incentives to get your players
to return each and every day.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: It's
especially important
to focus on the
group of users who
are less active two
to four days ago,
as these are the easiest to
convert to daily players.
Think about what
incentives can you
offer to have them come
back each and every day.
Can you strengthen
your return mechanics?
Can you personalize
a push notification?
Or can you leverage
your social system
to create extremely compelling
experiences to bring them back
day after day after day?
ADAM CARPENTER: In addition
to segmenting your users
by their daily last
active play, you
can also do the equivalent
thing for your revenue
and your buyers.
The charts we're looking
at here show the percentage
of revenue in the
percent of buyers
based on when those users
last paid in the game.
And the way to calculate
this, for example,
let's say it's today.
Take all the revenue
you earned from today,
and then segment it,
create sections and slices
based on when those users
previously paid in the game.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: Views
like this are very valuable
to understand when, where,
and how your players perceive
value in your game.
For example, look at this
graph, and ask what percentage
is your first-time buyers.
If you are relatively
new game, and you
see a high percentage
of first-time buyers,
that's to be expected.
But this number should be
trending down over time
as you convert your first-time
buyers into repeated buyers.
So if you're
relatively mature game
and you still see a very high
first-time buyer percentage,
ask yourself what's
incentivizing
a user to purchase
once, but not again?
ADAM CARPENTER:
Likewise, take a look
at the percent of your
daily buyers and revenue
which is coming from
users who purchased
in the last week, the last
month, or the last quarter,
and then think about what's
driving a specific purchase
frequency, and how players are
perceiving value in your game.
Think about what causes them to
open up their wallets and pay,
and when they do, are they
having a good experience?
Then, see if you
have the ability
to shift monthly buyers to
weekly, or quarterly buyers
to monthly.
If you're able to do this, it'll
help stabilize your revenue
and make it much
more predictable.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
Finally, we'd like
to encourage you to move
away from vanity metrics,
like DAU and revenue.
While these are important
business metrics that
measure the health
of your game, they
are just the end results,
not the leading indicators.
ADAM CARPENTER: Instead try to
identify a metric or metrics
which can serve as the most
meaningful and effective
representation of
engagement in your game.
Finding the right
participation metric
will let you identify
issues in the game
before they begin to
impact revenue and DAU.
As a broad concept,
participation
measures the percent
of your DAU who
are engaging in a critical
action on a given day.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: To
give you an example,
here are the ideas from
three popular genres.
Much like game developers
use level completion
as our participation
metric, players
who have been in
the level or those
who exit the game
before finishing
the level don't count.
Instead, they measure
the number of players
who played the level all the
way to the end whether they
pass or fail.
They use this as a
participation metric,
because it measures
a player's intent
to finish the level and
progress in the game.
It also has the added bonus
of surfacing monetization
opportunities when
players are out
of moves and need power-ups.
ADAM CARPENTER: In games
like slots or bingo--
social Casino genre,
et cetera, you
have some very interesting
dynamics in the game economy.
The way the game
economy works is,
whether its credits or its
coins, generally speaking,
players can accumulate a near
unlimited amount of resources.
So what you actually have is
a relatively large percent
of the DAU come back everyday
to collect their assets,
but they never actually consume
or spend any in the game.
This has led many
slots developers
to use the notion
that a user who
sinks coins playing a
slot machine for part
of their participation metric.
Or some of the even more
advanced slots developers,
their participation
metric is actually
the percent of their DAU
you who goes out of coins
playing on a given day.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: In
mythical strategy games
like War Dragons,
player interactions
are very important.
Paul [? Gayjan, ?]
the game developer,
tracked the number
of daily attacks
and participation
in weekly events.
When during attack, players are
actively engaged in gameplay.
Attacks also generate
two actions--
retaliation, and
base repairment.
Both increase a player's
investment in game and resource
consumption.
The same is true
for weekly events.
ADAM CARPENTER: In all
cases, participation
is critical, as it measures
the player's intent--
their desire to play.
We'd strongly encourage you
to explore your own data,
and figure out what your
key participation metric is,
as finding it will help you
better understand your players
and the overall
health of your game.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: Now suppose
you have the right team
structure, and by leveraging
their innate curiosity,
you're asking it all
the right questions.
But how do you find
the right answers?
The best answers cannot
be discovered in silo,
and the best solutions
often cover very different
perspectives.
To have that
diverse perspective,
it's important to have
the right team culture.
So ask this: what is
your team culture?
Is it open or is it closed?
Do you hold information tightly,
or do you share it widely?
ADAM CARPENTER: Sharing
thoughts, findings,
and insights--
they're absolutely critical
to your game's success.
And likewise, how you share
information is important.
Sharing data alone
is meaningless.
What you actually need to
do is share information,
which is data in context.
For while data by itself
can be interesting,
information is meaningful
and actionable.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: So open
up your weekly analytics
meetings to all of the key
stakeholders of your business.
Use these meetings as a
platform to not only discuss
past updates, events,
and sales, but also
ask probing questions to each
other, and brainstorm together.
ADAM CARPENTER: Likewise,
encourage your team
to make sharing a regular
part of their daily work.
If they are
investigating an issue
or trying improve a
feature, encourage
them to call a peer over,
talk through the trends
and patterns, understand
what's going on,
and ultimately
work to understand
and come up with
effective solutions.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
Now let's summarize.
What does it take to
identify opportunities
through games data?
ADAM CARPENTER:
First, if you want
to be able to identify
opportunities, the most
important thing is
to ensure that you're
recording absolutely everything
that's happening in your game.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: Second,
make sure you set up
an agile team
whose well-equipped
to not only interpret the
data, but to also take actions
based on these insights.
ADAM CARPENTER: And
then encourage your team
to be curious about
anything and everything.
Dig through the data, ask
questions, generate insights.
Always be curious about
what your users are valuing
in your game, and how you can
use your understanding of that
to improve your business
and drive long-term growth.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
Finally, encourage
that culture of sharing at
all levels of your company--
101, intra-team, as
well as company-wide.
ADAM CARPENTER: Thank you
guys very much for your time.
Hope it was interesting.
[APPLAUSE]
Now we're going to turn
it over to Belinda, who's
going to share some
updates about monetizing
with Google's ad platform.
BELINDA LANGNER: Good
afternoon, everyone.
How's everyone doing today?
Great.
It's really great to be
here at GDC with all of you.
I'm really excited to be able
to talk to you all about some
of the cool things that
our teams are working on.
So I'm Belinda Langner,
and I'm a Product Manager
working on Google's
mobile app ads business.
My job is to build
products for app developers
like yourselves to build
really great businesses,
and successful businesses,
by acquiring high-value users
through advertising.
And then Vishal is going
to come up and tell you
a little bit more about how you
can earn more for your players.
So let's go ahead
and get started,
and I'll tell you
a little bit more
about how Google can really
help grow your fan base.
So as we've heard from a
number of presenters today,
we know that there's a
tremendous opportunity
out their for game
developers today.
Mobile has really democratized
the entire gaming industry,
and made it more accessible to
more people than ever before.
In fact, today there are over
$2.6 billion gamers in 2017,
and that's compared to
100 million in 1995.
That's a huge growth curve
when you think about it,
and it makes product
managers like myself
and Vishal very
excited, obviously,
and it should make you
all very excited, too.
So 80% of mobile game players
today play at least once a day,
and that includes me.
I think, actually,
if you look back,
I never would have
called myself a gamer.
I've always really liked
playing board games
with my brother growing
up, and things like that.
But, like, when I used
to think of gamer,
I used to think of a very
different sort of profile.
But in fact, I spent a lot
of hours playing things
like Alphabears.
In fact, I played that over
on the BART ride in today
to the city.
And I just really enjoy
playing these games.
And I actually spend quite a bit
of time on my commute playing,
I spend quite a bit of time
when I wake up just kind of,
you know, playing to
kind put my mind off
of things a little bit, or you
know, at night, right before I
go to bed, just to kind
of relax a little bit
before I go to bed.
And so as more people
play, and as more people
like myself get
interested in games
with cute adorable
animals, there
are even more ways than ever
to build a profitable business
around games.
And we're here
today to talk to you
about the business of gaming,
and how Google ads can really
help you be successful.
So let's go ahead and
dive in a little bit more.
Starting with growth, I'm
going to talk a little bit more
about the tools
that can really help
grow a fan base for your games.
So I don't need to be the
one to tell you this, because
most likely you all know this.
Acquiring players for games
is highly competitive,
and the profile
of players playing
hard games versus hardcore
strategy games, versus games
that have cute, adorable animals
in it, is very quite different.
And it's even harder
to tell who's actually
going to be staying
engaged for longer,
and whether or not they're
going to spend within the app.
In addition, as the
gaming industry grows,
the profiles of these
people start to change.
And so what you think
of a traditional gamer,
and how you categorize
these, may not actually
tell the full story of
people who are actually
engaging with your game.
And that is where we can help.
In 2015, we launched Universal
App Campaigns, or UAC,
as a great way for developers to
automatically find and acquire
the right users across all
of our largest properties.
UAC has made marketing
better, easier, and simpler
for developers such as
yourselves to build and grow
your businesses.
And rather than
having to figure out
how each of the
nuances of our networks
work by adding
thousands of keywords
or individual testing--
a ton of headlines to see which
ones work best --developers now
are able to take advantage
of Google's machine learning
platform to do it all for them.
And performance
results for developers
have been great,
no matter if you're
a small developer or
a large developer,
no matter where you are
in your game life cycle.
And so let's go ahead and go
through a couple of examples.
Has anyone heard of the game
Power Pop Bubble Shooter Mania?
No?
Oh, a couple of people.
There we go.
So Ilyon Dynamics is the maker
of the hit game Power Pop
Bubble Shooter Mania,
and Ilyon wanted
to acquire new
players for Power Pop,
and to really increase
the revenue coming
from their in-app purchases
for new players acquired.
And so when they were looking
to grow their app installs,
and really increase out their
user base of paying users,
they looked at Google, and
used Universal App Campaigns,
and they found that UAC
delivered higher KPIs almost
across the board.
In fact, they saw that
the 90-day lifetime
value of these users was
actually 7.3 times higher,
and they actually saw
an average revenue
per user increase of five times
compared to their baseline.
In addition, the
day one retention
from these players that
they acquired through UAC
was actually 15% higher
than their organic users.
And the beauty of UAC is that
it's completely adaptable
to any game, to your
game, to your players,
and to your business.
And so let's just go
through another example.
Has anyone heard of Marvel's
Contest of Champions here?
OK.
Yeah.
So you can see, this
is a more popular game,
but we can really help you no
matter how small your game is,
or how big your game is.
And so Kabam is
an industry leader
here in massive mobile
multi-player games.
Kabam has accumulated
millions of downloads,
and you can tell--
obviously some of you guys
are in this room today
--and have received awards
such as Apple's Editors
Choice, and Google Play's
Best Game of the Year.
And so Kabam came to
us looking to increase
their daily active users for
the role-playing game Marvel's
Contest of Champions,
and they also
wanted to extend
their global reach.
They didn't want to
just reach one market,
but they really wanted
to kind of expand
beyond just their main market.
So they partnered with Google
and UAC to find new players,
and they included video
in their campaigns
to really let the strong
gameplay that they
have speak for itself.
And by doing so, they grew
their installs six times,
quarter over quarter,
reaching hundreds of thousands
of new users.
And in addition, their
conversion rate actually
increased 50% year
over year, and UAC
helped drive a 70% improvement
on their target return on ad
spend.
So how is USC
exactly doing this?
How are we helping developers
such as yourselves,
developers such as Kabam,
and developers such as Ilyon?
Well, we're using
machine learning
to make the smartest
decision for every single ad
that we serve,
analyzing hundreds
of millions of potential
combinations in real time,
finding out where people are
engaging with your ads, which
creatives work the best,
which queries are working
the best, which your users
are actually ultimately doing
the action that you care
about within your game,
whether it's purchases, whether
it's reaching a certain level,
whether it's just simply
engaging with your game,
learning about these converting
players to find more of them
over time.
And I'm really proud to say that
our investments are working.
We've recently passed a
really exciting milestone.
We've now driven over 10 billion
installs to date from our ads.
In addition, UAC
is actually helping
drive over 7 billion
in-app events per quarter,
like users reaching level 10, or
help making a certain purchase
within your game.
And so we're continuing
to double down on UAC now
with a lot of new inventions
being built into UAC,
and to make app promotion
even more effective.
So I'm going to go ahead and
dive in some of the cool things
that we're going to
actually be bringing to UAC.
And video is a really
key format by which
you're able to pique the
interests of your users.
Because after all,
you kind of want
to understand how the game
works before you download it.
There are so many
choices out there.
How do you know that you're
going to like the game?
And that's why video ads has
been so successful in driving
app installs.
In addition, we're trying to
unlock even more opportunities
for us where we can really
show how to find users,
and show users how
great your game is.
And one of those great
areas is Google Play.
More than one
billion people visit
Google Play each month from over
190 countries around the world.
It's the place where
users come to develop
apps and games like the
ones that you all develop.
And beyond just searching
for new apps to try,
we're seeing that more and more
users are browsing the Play
Store, and trying to find
the recommendations that
come from the Play
Store about which games
or which apps they should
download and give a shot.
And so to help users
discover more of your apps,
and really amplify
your video ads,
we're rolling out a new
beta for our video ads.
And so now we're offering
a new way for you
to reach your users with your
video ads in Google Play.
And these new placements
will be available
exclusively through UAC
to help you reach users
with high-impact
video ads as they
type, they swipe, and
scroll through all
the different results in search
of their next new favorite
game, which hopefully
is yours, right?
And with a world of games
available on mobile,
it can be hard to know who might
fall in love with your game.
And it's not just video
ads that will really
help encourage and
find the right users,
but we also know that you want
to find users who actually will
really start to engage, and
do the actions that you care
the most about, like the
ones who are likely to beat
that first level, get
through a tutorial,
or make an in-app purchase.
And so we're introducing
Similar Audiences for UAC
to help you find people
who share similar interests
with the best customers
that you already have,
and that you already
know about, right when
they're interested in games
and with apps like yours.
So imagine that you have
a popular mobile game,
and you're working on your
next new launch release.
You actually have a whole
list of users from your games
that work really well.
And so you can get
that list to Google,
and we'll actually be able to
find more players like those
playing your current game.
By connecting the
information that you give us
with more qualified
customers, Similar Audiences
can really help unlock
more of the information
that you know already
works well for you,
and really help you grow your
business even more and faster.
And this will be available to
select advertisers starting
later this year, in a
couple of months, in May,
and we're really excited to
see what you all do with this.
And so now I'm going
to pass it over
to Vishal to tell
you a little bit more
about how you can earn
more from the players
that hopefully you
just acquired from UAC.
[APPLAUSE]
VISHAL KUMAR: Hi, everyone.
My name is Vishal
Kumar, and I am
a Product Manager at Google on
the Mobile Apps Modernization
Team.
My team's goal is
to help developers
like yourself maximize the
amount of money they make
from their apps, and to do
this in the most easiest way
possible.
Today I am here to share some
of the latest and greatest ideas
and innovations that
our team is working on.
So let's go ahead and
jump right into it.
I think everybody in
this room has a passion
for building legendary games.
But to build those
games, you need
the cash flow to sustain it.
The hard truth is that
not all your players
are able or willing to
pay for those games.
And then even those
non-spenders actually
need compelling
gaming experiences.
In the last year, we
have seen the explosion
in the growth of hybrid
models where publishers
are using ads and
in-app purchases
to maximize the
monetization of their games.
In fact, in the last year
alone mobile gaming apps
using hybrid models
have seen 50% growth
on the Google Play Store.
We believe that by supplementing
your IP-focused games with ads,
you can actually
engage more players
and reach out to a
larger audience, in fact
almost anyone with
a mobile phone.
However, one concern that
we hear from publishers
is that they believe ads might
cannibalize IP purchases.
We get that.
That's actually why we
released the Prediction Tool
in our app development
platform, Firebase.
So what the
predictions that you do
is segment of players based
on predicted behaviors
into likely spenders
and likely non-spenders.
That means that you can
show ads to a huge majority
of your players that are
most likely not going
to spend inside the game.
This is a huge revenue
opportunity for publishers
today.
One of our partners,
[? Rockboy ?] Games,
used the prediction tools to
actually segment their user
base into spenders
and non-spenders,
and then they used
this data to create
Play-customized digital
store experiences
based on the prediction.
They drove a 25%
increase in revenue
using the tool and the
different sharing experience.
So we believe that
ads are a great way
to monetize your apps.
However, these ads need to
be of really high quality.
We believe that the best
ad experiences actually
provide value to users,
value to advertisers
by delivering engaged users, and
much more revenue for the app
publisher.
For the non-spending audience,
it's also really critical
to make sure that
we do not sacrifice
the gameplay experience.
Because even if they're
not willing to pay
with their money,
they are likely
willing to pay with their time.
Rewarded ads offer a
non-intrusive opt-in way
to allow these
large non-spenders
to engage with an ad and get
something of value in return.
Our data shows that
when used correctly,
these ads can actually
increase playtime
while ensuring that
publishers get paid.
As you can see,
some of these users
actually talk about these
ads in the App Store reviews,
and actually we've
even seen them
complain when we pull these
ads from some of the games.
Of the top 1,000 ad publishers
by revenue, over 40% of them
are now using rewarded
ads in their games.
Another benefit we
see is that developers
who actually start using
rewarded ads in their games
actually end up seeing
more engaged users,
because the users actually
appreciate the value
exchange, which makes
the gameplay more
engaging and rewarding.
Avidly, one of our publishers
who publishes Bingo Party,
actually saw a 40%
growth in total revenue
once they introduced rewarded
ads into their games,
and 20% longer session lengths
due to the increased engagement
from rewarded ads.
Today I also wanted
to talk to you
about some of the
new experiences
that our team is
releasing in rewarded ads.
So on the left-hand
side, we have
something that we call
the rewarded playable.
This is kind of like a
try-before-you-buy sort of ad
format.
And the other interesting thing
is it actually keeps the player
inside the gaming
experience so you
get the maximum
monetization and engagement.
On the right side we
have something that we
call multiple rewarded ads.
In this particular
example, not only
are you offering the user
the choice to see an ad,
you're actually offering them
a choice of which ad to see.
And our data shows
that when you actually
design the format in
this way, users actually
end up picking an ad that
they have some investment in,
they end up being more
engaged in the ad,
and that results in
more conversions.
These formats have been
designed specifically
to make sure that
when you do try
to monetize your non-spenders,
you do not end up sacrificing
the in-game experience.
Another important
piece of monetization
is making sure that you're
optimizing every opportunity
to own revenue.
And normally this is met
using mediation and working
with many different
network partners.
Mediation is a crucial
strategy for our publishers
to help them find
niche markets of demand
across geo and format.
In theory, mediation ensures
that you're getting the highest
CPM for every impression
by making sure
that the networks that have
historically offered the best
performance get called
first, and then you
proceed down a daisy chain.
But what happens when a
lower-priority network
is actually willing to pay more
for a particular impression?
That's actually where we
believe we can come in and help.
With the new product
that we just announced,
which is called
Open Bidding, we now
take the promise of
monetization to the next level.
First, we make it
easier than ever
for you to manage all
your different networks.
Secondly, we help you get
the most value for your ads,
because with Open Bidding,
all your different partners
are going to compete for
the inventory simultaneously
and in real time.
Again, our data shows
that when this happens,
it drives the performance for
the publisher much higher,
resulting in much
higher monetization.
Open Bidding also has
some other benefits
beyond just increased revenue.
Simplified reporting, and
also potentially reduced
SDKs should help you reduce
your operational expenditure.
Our team is super
excited about continuing
to build the tools that
help you grow your business,
grow your revenue, and
grow your audience.
Since 2012, the AdMob
team has paid out
over $3.5 billion dollars to
all the different app developers
to help them stay focused
on their mission of creating
legendary games.
Now-- so here are some of the
other sessions that we have,
if you're interested in
anything that you've heard,
and you'd like to learn
more, please come talk to me,
or attend one of our
sessions this week.
I'm now going to hand it
off to Dave Geffon, who's
going to talk to you about
building communities,
and expanding your
reach through YouTube.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE GEFFON: Hi, everyone.
My name is Dave Geffon.
I'm the head of the Gaming
Content & Partnerships
team at YouTube.
And my team's responsible for
the growth of gaming content
in the Americas for YouTube.
And what we do is work
with game developers,
publishers, and creators to help
them succeed on the platform.
One of the most common
questions we get
is just about how to
get started on YouTube.
It's a huge platform.
I think everyone knows
it's worthy of investment.
They just don't quite
know where to start.
So today we're going to talk
about some immediate steps you
can take to succeed
on the platform
that anyone, regardless
of resources and time,
should be able to do.
So let's just talk about YouTube
by the numbers for a second.
We don't need to spend
a ton of time on this.
I think everyone can universally
recognize that YouTube is
an absolutely massive platform.
But you know, just
calling out a couple
of things that jump out to me.
So Tubular Labs did
a study recently
where they quantified that more
than 325 billion views in 2017
coming from YouTube
were marked as gaming--
really huge and really
impressive numbers.
In a similar study, Newsoo
had over two billion people
playing games globally.
So a massive total
addressable market.
So the audience is there,
the demand is there,
and there's clearly people
engaging with and watching
video content like never before.
So what are these things that
you can do to get started?
Really these are tips that
we would give to developers
or publishers of any size.
Behind closed doors,
in a session like this,
there's some really
baseline things
that you can do to succeed.
The first is to educate
yourself on the platform.
You can't succeed unless you
really know what's happening
and why.
Create your own content.
Establish the tone and
voice for your game
in your IP on YouTube, and
let your fans follow suit.
Leverage the tools and tech
that YouTube invests in.
We're really invested
in helping people
create great content on YouTube,
and have a lot of unique tools
to help that happen.
And finally, work with
your biggest fans.
Collaborate.
Know who your biggest supporters
are, and support them.
So it goes without saying that
it's really important to have
a baseline level of
proficiency and knowledge
when it comes to YouTube.
YouTube has been
around for 13 years.
The YouTube Creator Academy and
the YouTube Certified programs
are amazing educational
resources developed
by the YouTube
team to help anyone
from the most basic user to
the most advanced succeed
on the platform.
These educational modules cover
things from metadata how-tos,
like how to use thumbnails
to optimize clicks,
all the way up to content
rights, copyright claiming,
and so forth.
You don't need to become
an expert overnight,
but as you're getting started,
if you have a question
and you are looking
for an answer,
this is a really
good place to be.
And I think one thing that's
really important to mention,
and one thing that we don't
see a lot of at times,
is the follow-through
and commitment
to refreshing your knowledge
and understanding how
the platform changes.
One really easy and quick
tip that we offer people
is to follow the Creator
Academy on YouTube.
They often will publish
videos and how-tos
on some of the biggest
issues changing on YouTube,
and it's a really great
way to casually keep
track of what's happening, and
decide what matters to you.
Again, the platform is changing,
and what you knew 12 months ago
may not be relevant today.
So stay up to date in your
understanding of what's
going on the platform.
The most obvious
and the biggest one
is to create what you view
as exemplar content of videos
around your game.
It gives you the
opportunity to set
the tone, the voice, the
style, and how you want your IP
to be perceived.
Is it irreverent?
Is it comedic?
Is it more serious?
That's only for you to decide.
And if you look at partners
like Seriously, who've
been so committed to
doing this with their Best
Fiends franchise,
there's no question
as to what they
want their IP to be.
And you see on every
piece of content
that they create
on the platform.
And that's really borne out
of this idea of consistency.
There's no shortcuts
to success on YouTube.
There's no silver bullet.
It's about hard work
and consistency,
and doing that's going to give
you the best chance to succeed.
Miniclip is a great example that
we point to that consistency
just pays off.
They created their own
great content around Agario,
they collaborated with fans,
they featured different pieces
of content that created
variety on their channel,
and their fans responded.
They actually achieved more
than one million subscribers
in less than a year, which is
a phenomenal and tremendous
effort.
And how they did that,
they leveraged tools.
And this is something
that everybody
should be doing on YouTube.
Google is primarily known as
a engineering-first culture,
and we build great tools.
We build great tech
to help you succeed.
One example, especially for game
developers and publishers just
getting started on the platform,
is using the new Community tab.
And what the Community
tab allows you to do
is bring content that
is non-video gaming
content into your subscriber
feed for your channel
to engage with your
audience while you're still
developing video content
for the first time.
So imagine yourself engaging
with your audience with a poll.
What new video content
would you like to see?
Or a static image releasing
a new champion or hero
into your game.
It takes some of the
pressure off of you
when you're just
getting started,
and it's something
that we are seeing fans
engaging with all the time.
Two other big
products that we think
are super-relevant for mobile
developers are cards and end
cards.
So cards are
something that you can
include into the
middle of a video that
lets you track an action.
In this case, you know, Rovio
is doing a great job using cards
to redirect interested users
from their Angry Birds 2
trailer to the Google
Play Store to measure
the effectiveness
of their videos
and understand how
this is performing
as an install channel.
They can follow that up with
things like end cards, that
allows you to cross-promote and
continue getting users engaged
with content on your channel
that's relevant to them.
The tools, the tech is there.
Just understanding how to
use them is really key.
Finally, collaborate
with your fans.
Know who your biggest
supporters are,
recognize them, and
support their content.
Supercell is a
developer who we've
seen do an amazing job working
with their biggest supporters
and creators to help
supplement their content,
be part of the narrative
and part of the process
of their biggest
moments for their games,
whether it's Clash of
Clans and a new Town Hall
update, or Clash
Royale, and a new card.
Having your fans
involved is a great way
to ensure authenticity,
but a unique tone and voice
that only that they can
bring to your games.
And one really
obvious one is just
support and recognize the
fans in your community.
It goes a long way.
The people who are creating
content around games
are doing so because
they love these games,
first and foremost.
And recognizing
their contribution
to the community,
and what they've
done to help your games,
can go a long, long way.
So pulling it all together.
Think about education as
the baseline and foundation
for your YouTube experience.
The more familiar you are with
the inner workings of YouTube,
the more likely
you are to succeed.
Second, create your own content.
Take the time to establish what
your games and what your IP
should be on YouTube.
Show your community,
show your fans
that this is what excellence
with your games looks like
and represents.
Collaborate with fans.
Just work with them to bring
their passion to the forefront,
and recognize it
on your channel.
And finally, leverage the tech
and tools that we make that
will help you reach
more fans, succeed,
and share a greater level
of success on the platform.
Thank you very
much, and I would--
sorry.
Go ahead.
[APPLAUSE]
Now that that's
out of the way, I
want to welcome up Toshi
from Bandai Namco, who's
been doing some really
interesting work with Google
Cloud, and he'd love
to share it with you.
[APPLAUSE]
TOSHITAKA TACHIBANA: Thank you.
All right.
Hello, everybody.
Good evening, or afternoon--
I can't tell what
time it is right now.
I'm sorry.
KEIGO IKEDA: Hi, I'm Keigo.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
TOSHITAKA TACHIBANA:
And my name is Toshi.
I'm also part of the Dragon
Ball app Produce Team,
and I'll be doing
most of the talking,
as, fortunately for my
job, Keigo can't exactly
talk in English.
So-- I'm sorry.
He understands it, though.
So, Moving on.
Just before starting on into
the presentation itself,
I want to talk a little
bit about our company.
We-- Bandai Namco
Entertainment--
create video games, ranging from
console, to PC, to mobile apps,
as you can see on
the screen right now.
And most of our games actually
are based on Japanese IPs.
So examples would be Dragon
Ball, One Piece, Idol Master,
Sword Art Online, Naruto--
I can just keep going
on and on and on.
But maybe some of you have seen
it, some of you have played it.
But today that's not what we're
really here to talk about.
Today we're actually here
to talk about something
new, something I'm
really-- both of us,
Keigo and I --are really
excited to talk about.
It's a new PVP game,
and actually we've
never released any
new information
regarding this until now.
So you guys are the first to
see anything about this game.
So without further ado, I
give you Dragon Ball Legends.
It's an all-new
title of mobile app
that will be released in 2018.
And as you can
see on the screen,
the game play will be in
3D, heavily action-oriented,
and also we're pretty excited
to talk about it today.
We made sure that the details
and everything are all fine
tuned so that it's exactly
what the Dragon Ball
fans wanted on a mobile app.
So one of the biggest features
that we have for this game
actually is the global real
time player-versus-player
on cloud network.
So let me say that
one more time.
It's global, it's real
time, and it is actually
player-versus-player.
It's-- we're not going to
muck around with by providing
pseudo-experiences of
player-versus-player where
players fight other player data.
It's not going to be like that.
We'll actually have
the players be fighting
one-on-one, anywhere, anytime.
So you know what, to give you
a really good idea as to what
it will be like,
we're actually going
to have a live demonstration
between two points.
And point A being here,
Moscone Center, where Keigo
will be playing against another
team member of ours that
is currently in Japan--
our Tokyo
headquarters, actually.
So I just copy and pasted
the Google map, actually,
but you as you can see,
there's 5,100 miles apart.
Yeah, that's [? Ayaka, ?]
one of our team members.
And so she's currently
in Tokyo right now.
The right screen is
her mobile app screen.
Left screen is Keigo's.
And I would appreciate
it if the audio
was played in the background
a little bit louder.
Yes, thank you.
OK, so the game
itself is one-on-one,
but each player can bring up
to three playable characters.
The objective of the game is
to defeat the opponent's three
characters before the opponent.
All right, and
they're both ready.
So thanks to Google's
Cloud Networking,
we managed to create a
really stable playing field
where users don't really need to
worry about internet connection
latency and whatnot.
All they need to worry
about is the opponent
that's going to be in front
of them on the screen.
All right.
It seems like the
game connected.
And it's still black.
Oh, there we go.
Thank God.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- You can't beat me.
TOSHITAKA TACHIBANA: So the
game's started right now.
Left screen is Keigo.
He will probably show off
some of the cool cut scenes
that each character has, but
it's heavily action-oriented.
But in actuality, the
controls are quite simple.
He made sure that
it's intuitive,
and we made sure
that everybody who
wants an action
game on Dragon Ball
can play other players without
having to worry about getting
their butt handed to them.
So as you can see,
[? Ayaka ?] just
activated her special skill.
The four cards that can
be seen on the bottom
of the screen, those
are universal cards
that each player has.
And whenever you tap
them, the character
will automatically do an action
oriented to that specific card.
And each character will
have something different.
For example, you
tap the red card,
you can do a melee attack.
You tap the yellow card,
you can do a long ranged,
and the blue one is
a special attack.
And also by tapping
them consecutively,
the character will
automatically create combos.
So just like right
now, actually.
It's a special cut
scene right now.
And it looks really complex
when you first see it, honestly.
But-- oh my God.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHS]
Yeah, see.
She had no choice.
He's her boss.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Back to the
presentation, please.
All right.
Thank you.
[END PLAYBACK]
So as you can see,
the game itself
runs actually fairly smoothly,
even though the connection
was done over the ocean.
Players who are outside the
country that you're living in
can obviously definitely
fight against you
with no worries about latency--
any problems in network lag
or whatsoever, thanks to
the Google Cloud platform.
Honestly, we could not have
realized this entire project
without this service.
And also, as for
the second point
as to why we used GCP,
this entire title,
this is going to be a flagship
title of sorts for us.
It's going to be on a whole new
level of just entire bigness.
So we know that there's going to
be an immense amount of traffic
coming in.
And the bigger
the traffic is, we
need to make sure that the
infrastructure can handle it--
more database, more
sharding, and whatnot.
And the bigger the system
gets, the more complex it gets.
And inevitably
leading to higher--
just human error, and
higher chance of human error
happening, and higher cost
for taking care of it.
And when we have
a title like this
where we have
hundreds of thousands
of users constantly
playing against each other,
we want to make sure
that they always
have the right experience,
and that we prepared for them.
So in order to do that, we
utilized the Cloud Spanner
to create a more
simpler architecture,
so that we don't
really need to worry
too much about human error
happening, or other costs that
might happen.
So another thing that
we use that GCP for
is Stackdriver
logging and BigQuery.
Like you might have heard
a couple minutes ago,
we want to record
literally everything.
We want to make sure that we can
see what the users are doing,
and the key performance
indicators are used properly,
so that we can create a constant
content update where users have
something new to do,
users have something
to come back to, maybe every
other day, hopefully every day.
But we want to create a content
that's constantly evolving.
So this is an
architecture diagram
of that we're going to be
using for this project.
Who here can read this?
Hands up.
Yeah, I can't.
But I know what Keigo
told me to talk about.
So this is basically just
an idea of the architecture
diagram where--
how the user connects
to the administrator.
But in the end, we are
going to be providing
this service as one big server.
We're not going to be
separating by regions or areas
like you might see in
certain large ARP MMORPGs,
because that would
then kind of lose
the point of having a global
PVP system to begin with.
We want to make sure that
every fighter can fight
on the fighter that's on
the other side of the world
anytime they want, so that they
can just gloat and literally
say that they are the best.
So to reiterate, the GCP was
essential in this project.
We could not have done this
player-versus-player connection
where you don't really need to
worry about the game play being
affected by network
lags and such,
even if you're connecting
to a character player that's
on the other side of the world.
And also, we wanted to
make sure that we create
a constant contact update
with actual quality,
and provide something
the users wanted--
or maybe didn't even
know they wanted
--but were satisfied with.
So we need to make sure that we
record everything, and provide
for a proper
large-scale service.
And of course, we
just want to make sure
that every fighter just
deserves a solid connection.
They only need to focus on
the enemy in front of them.
They don't need to worry about
the extra connection issues
or technical difficulties.
They just need to
figure out how hard they
need to punch the other person.
So before we end
this presentation,
I actually have a bit
of a shameless promotion
that I want to talk
to you guys about.
Tomorrow, 10:30 AM,
we'll be holding
a livestream where
we'll be announcing
a lot more details
regarding this game title,
such as other playable
characters-- you
might have seen Goku, or
Piccolo, Frieza, and Napa.
We have loads more that we
want to definitely talk about.
Unfortunately, I barely
have any time left.
So you guys hopefully access
this livestream tomorrow.
We'll I also have
Miles Ward joining us
as a special guest from
Google Cloud Solutions,
and he'll be talking a bit more
about the technology that was
used to make this product work.
So, thank you for listening.
Keigo will be saying goodbyes.
KEIGO IKEDA: Thank
you for listening.
We hope that we can be a
new benchmark in global PVP.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TOSHITAKA TACHIBANA: So
next up, we have Nico to--
I'm sorry.
That's not the right one.
King-- the next
presentation is from King.
STEFAN FREYR: Hello.
My name is Stefan Freyr.
I'm the Research Lead at King.
And I'm going to
tell you about how
we were able to increase
the speed of play testing
with deep learning
from about seven days
to seven minutes using
Google Cloud Platform.
First of all, so this
is where we operate.
We're a mobile game,
and King is most famous
for Candy Crush, of course.
And Candy Crush has been able to
stay on top for five years now,
which is pretty
unusual in this market.
There are many reasons
for this, but we
think one of the main
reasons is that we have been
very data-driven from day one.
Today, we run hundreds of A/B
tests in our games per year,
and we do that in an
automated framework.
And we realize how
important it is
to have this kind of
automated framework
where we can have a very fast
iteration loop of what we do,
and I'll come back
to that later.
The agenda for the
talk is simple.
I'll just explain our
problem with play testing,
and present our
solution, and how that
connects with Google
Cloud Platform.
Here are a few examples of what
we do within our team, AI R&D
team King.
And the problem I'm
presenting is the top one,
creating convolutional
neural network bots
for automatic play testing.
First of all, what
is Candy Crush?
I'm assuming that most
of you have played it
or understand the gameplay.
If you haven't,
just download it.
So game specifics-- the
game is not deterministic.
There are random
elements in the game.
It has a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] space,
and today we have more
than 3,000 unique levels
in the game.
Every week, we send out 15
new levels to our players.
That means that
our level designers
have to be very fast and
very creative to come up
with new levels every week.
What they have to think
about is- for example,
this --they have to think
about the looks of the level.
It has to look good--
symmetry, things like that.
There is a strategic element
in most of the levels.
Here is an example
of a level where
you have a lot of blockers in
the lower part of the board,
where it is almost impossible to
make any movements or actions,
and the strategy
for this level is
to try to break down
to the lower levels
as fast as possible.
But one of the
most important part
that level designers
have to think about
is the balancing of the level.
What does that mean?
It means that the level cannot
be too easy, too trivial,
and it is no--
there's no challenge, no
stimulation for the player,
and it cannot be too hard,
because then there is no
feeling of reward
you feel every time.
So it's extremely important
to get the right balance
of difficulty of finding
the just-right difficulty
for a level.
So how do we do that?
This is what we used to do.
We have level designers think
about the level of creation.
That takes time-- all
these three elements
that I mentioned
before --and then
you send it out for
human play testing.
And that took seven days.
So seven days later, we get a
feedback from the play testers,
and they tell us for
the new 15 levels,
for example, Level 3
and 4, they're too easy;
level 15 is too difficult. And
the only thing we can do that
is tweak these three
levels, and ship the episode
with 15 levels.
So we have no guarantee for the
sort of just-right measurement.
We only know that we were
able to improve, hopefully,
Levels 3, 4, and 15.
We would like to improve this.
And that's our problem.
And you can see that
at least seven days--
probably a little
bit more --taking
the time of the level designers,
is taken in just balancing.
So how can we
improve play testing?
How can we improve the speed
of play testing, accuracy,
everything?
With the recent breakthrough
in AI and games,
we thought, OK,
maybe we can build
a bot that can play like a
human-- imitate human play.
So this is an
interesting AI problem,
because everything
we've heard so far
would suggest that we should
build Alpha Candy Zero,
the best Candy player ever.
But that's not the problem.
We want to find an AI bot that
can play the game in the most
human-like way.
So what did we do?
We started gathering data.
That's always the first step.
We tracked data from players.
We tracked the
state action pair.
For every action
they could take,
we recorded everything
in the level,
the home state, and
the action taken.
This we can fit--
we tracked a bunch of this
data from all of our players
over some time period.
And then we can fit that into
a convolutional neural network,
which is the usual approach
for image recognition.
And we can train a
supervised policy network
based on this, a
network that can
learn from the input,
the state, and predict
the most common human
move in that position.
And what we do
when we have this,
then we can use
this policy network
that plays like a human.
We can upload that
to some cloud,
and let it play the game--
the new content of the game
--the new levels several times
to give us estimate of the
difficulty of new levels.
So can we have a video here?
So on the right, we see the
bot playing the same level
I showed you before.
On top left, we see
the communication.
So the agent playing the
level sends the state
to a policy network that
gives back, OK, I think
you should play this move.
It's the most human
move in the position.
And the bottom left, we show
the tracking-- actually now,
we're tracking the bot instead
of the humans as we did.
And you see that the bot
is playing quite well
in this level.
And we tried these levels
ourselves a few times.
And the bot was actually better
than some of us in the team.
This was very
interesting, but normal
if we believe that it is
learning the actual play.
And it was able to
solve the level in this.
If you go back to the slides.
And so this is the framework we
had in Google Cloud Platform.
And I said I wanted to come back
to the setup we had for our A/B
test framework, where
we learned that it
was so important to
have a framework that
can work fast and reliably,
and give fast iteration loops.
That is exactly the problem
we had with our play testing
solution.
In this era of AI
and machine learning,
it's rather easy to come
up with interesting ideas
to improve your business--
improve your processes
--but then you're
left with something.
You have a proof of concept.
You have a test environment.
But it's not creating real
value for the business
until it's a production,
a product which
is scalable, and stable, and
all these things that you need.
And we realized that we
were a rather small team.
We had this test
environment where everybody
was fighting for resources--
different games
than Candy Crush.
We wanted to test out more.
So we had to move it.
We moved it to Google
Cloud Platform,
and it was surprisingly
easy and surprisingly fast.
So this is the setup we have.
I don't have a pointer on this.
You can see on the
top right that's
the UI for the level designers.
Then we have an API service
that talks to the Google Cloud
Platform, where we
have cloud Pub/Sub,
and cloud data flow to sort of
plan and distribute the work.
The game engine agent
lives in Kubernetes,
where we can have
hundreds of agents playing
the game, basically working
as hundreds of play testers,
and they communicate with the
model serving with the policy
network that feeds
back the suggested
human moves in each position.
So that's how we
can sort of evaluate
the difficulty of newer levels
with this kind of setup.
OK.
So what does it mean
for our business?
Before, we had this,
and now we have
something like this,
where the level
designers are able to have
very fast iteration loops.
And as I said before, that is
the key to value for business.
The value for
business is not being
able to prove that
there is a solution.
It's being able to create
the solution very fast.
So level designers are now
able to iterate on their level
design.
And what used to take up to
seven days of play testing
takes now about seven minutes.
And this allows level
designers to focus
more on innovation and creation,
and being creative instead
of focusing on the balance.
They can just test
that very quickly.
And we're hoping that this will
help Candy Crush and our games
to stay on top for at
least another five years.
[LAUGHTER]
Why do you laugh?
OK.
End my talk, and
I'll hand it over
to Kacey, who will
wrap up the day.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KACEY FAHEY: Hi, everyone.
I'm Kacey Fahey, and I focus
on Games Developer Marketing
at Google Play.
I want to say a quick thank
you so much for coming out
to the Developer
Day today, and we
hope you walk away
with excitement
about some of the
announcements we've made,
and lots of tips and actionable
takeaways that you can go
continue to build amazing
games that you guys do.
Seriously, they keep us
so busy, and it's so fun
that this is our job
to play your games.
Two quick pieces of information
up on the screen here.
If you don't mind, we've built
a mobile-friendly, very short
survey that should take no more
than two minutes of your time.
And we literally go through
every piece of feedback.
So this is what helps us build
the better content each year
after year.
So either hop on your
phones, or jot it down,
but goo.fl/gdc2018.
And secondly, later in the
week, Wednesday through Friday,
stopped by Moscone South
at the Google booth,
where you can hear more Google
Talks, see product demos,
and any questions you may
have come up with today,
there's an Ask the Experts desk.
So that's it for today,
and have a great GDC.
Thank you.
[R&B MUSIC PLAYING]